let me start by saying congratulations
on your movie uh you did such such a
great job on your debut feature um so
you you're obviously doing a lot of
speed dating right now meeting a lot of
reporters talking about the film yeah is
it something that you're enjoying or is
there an element of like kubric where
you wish you could just like let the
movie Stand you know and not talk about
it no I mean you know it's uh no I I
think I'm you know I'm definitely I'm
definitely enjoying the process I think
you know I wish I got a little more
sleep you know but but uh no it's it's
you know this is something that I've
I've worked for you know and almost
killed myself to get made so you know
I'm I'm excited that people want to talk
about it what's this is a little bit of
a jokey question but uh it's amazing to
me that people still date their
co-workers yes yeah but you know what
it's like it it makes a lot of sense
when you think about it cuz it's like
these are the people you're around all
the time you're developing bonds and you
know relationships with and um you know
in in many ways it's like your
colleagues it's it's like a marriage you
know and and uh and um so I mean it
makes sense to me why why so many people
you know end up falling for people that
they work with absolutely um I'm curious
how much did you debate what your first
feature was going to be in terms of the
story you wanted to tell because there's
a lot of people that get one chance to
make a movie and you know it it's a I
can only imagine what it's like thinking
about is this the story that's going to
be my debut totally and I think I
struggled with that for many years
before I found this this film and this
story I think that I I was writing a lot
of different things and and and
searching and um and um and I just kept
going because whatever I was writing I
didn't think was good enough or I didn't
think was timely enough or I didn't
think was you know piercing enough uh
and so I just I just kept searching and
in the time that I was searching and
writing um life was happening and uh
there there was certain things um in my
life you know and certain experiences
that I had that it just became clear
that that's what I wanted to base it off
of you know cuz uh you know so a lot of
this you know this film is is deeply
personal you know and and and and I took
from some of my own experiences and um
and I you know that that's some of the
reason why you know I made this film and
and um and certain dynamics that I was
having one of the things about the film
is if you just examine it uh from the
outside it's basically a two location
setup yeah and I'm curious how much did
you think about I how can I tell this
story while also being limited with my
resources was that in your the writing
process were you thinking about that I
wanted to create you know this this
pressure cooker Thriller and this
ticking time bomb and I thought that
that
um what would add to that is if these
characters are you know stuck in this
kind of toxic bubble you know and and
and going from the apartment to the
office back to the apartment back to the
office and the idea that there's no
escape from each other you know
especially as things start to um start
to implode and unravel between them so
so uh for me that that's that's what
drew me to to setting the film between
those two spaces and creating two very
different looks of claustrophobia one of
the things that people might not know is
that you were one of the big if not the
biggest sale at Sundance um and I'm just
curious after spending so much time
making this what was it like being in
that Whirlwind where all of a sudden you
know it's just this huge success I mean
it you know it was uh it wasn't it was a
blur to be honest most of it was was a
blur but uh no it's incredibly rewarding
because uh you know I put everything
into this film and and uh it was it was
a painful journey to to get to making
this movie you know and and this is the
thing I set out to do and and there's
nothing more rewarding than than
um first of all just people you know
reacting the way that you want them to
react and and asking you know the kinds
of questions you know the same kinds of
questions that drove me to writing this
film and and and starting that kind of
conversation and that buzz and that
debate so I think for me like primarily
you know aside from the sale it was
really about the audience reaction first
and foremost you know and then of course
the sale was incredibly exciting and
rewarding so I haven't spoken to you
before but I love talking about the
editing process because it's where it
all comes together so um how did the
film change in the editing room in ways
perhaps you didn't expect I think the
editing was a lot of
um just really shaping this thing like a
bullet you know and um and uh it was
funny my my editor Franklin you know we
had talked about like at a certain point
we're like we have to we have to put a
gun to every scene's head and say
Justify Your Existence you know and I
think uh to to to shape this film like a
bullet um so you know through that
process we we we cut some scenes and um
and then and then just just really uh it
was it was honestly a lot I think the
biggest challenge of of the editing
process was
um uh both challenging but also at the
same time exciting which was like this
is a film where you if you dial a little
bit more towards Emily it completely
changes how you think about Luke the
next 30 minutes of the film and in from
one scene you dial a little bit towards
him a little bit you know too much
towards him it completely changes how
you think about her so this was a very
tricky film um because uh you know and
what I what you know where my empathy
goes or you know how I'm looking at the
characters or judging the characters or
empathizing with the characters is going
to be completely different from how
someone else is looking at it so you
know it was a it was just that that was
I think the trickiest part in just in
just uh trying to do a temperature check
you know with each of the characters and
how you feel about them in any given
moment and and um and just playing with
that so with with with with one with a
look you know with a comment you know
and and um with a hesitation and and uh
so that's more I think what what what we
uh explored I think in the edit in the
edit process your film uh has a few
intimate scenes and it feels like over
the last two decades Hollywood is like
afraid to show Intimacy in movies did
you find that people were resistant to a
script that had intimate scenes or do
you know what I mean because it's I mean
I you know honestly I just I feel really
lucky and grateful that I I met um uh
producers and um Finance years like
right away who got this movie who um
were behind my vision for it who didn't
question surprisingly I thought that I
would get some push back on on um on
some of you know the sexual nature of it
you know in some way and and um and I
didn't like these were people who just
who understood the movie that I was
making understood the importance of
those scenes and how it spoke to um the
power Dynamic you know struggle that I
was that I was uh exploring so I I um
yeah I think that it was
um it was and it was just because that I
had found people that I'd found the
right people for the movie to make this
with me one of the things I'm curious
about is uh they very powerful scenes
and and some fun some powerful how much
did you think about filming these near
each other or how much did you want to
space them out in the shoot or was it
sort of just the schedule is a schedule
I mean yeah I think that you try to do
that but ultimately the schedule is the
schedule um but I do think what's what's
you know we we talked I talked about
with my ad I said you know uh can we try
to schedule some of the lighter scenes
you know up front and make make our way
into you know some of the darker scenes
and but the truth is like the film gets
pretty tense pretty quickly so there are
very few light scenes to start with you
know so we were just but that's what
everyone signed up for so the actors
were game for it I was game for it it's
like let's just dive in head first and
just go for it I know that you guys were
able to do rehearsals which is pretty
unusual nowadays so what did you learn
in the rehearsal process that possibly
impacted the film or changed the script
in an unexpected way I mean rehearsals
are invaluable I don't know how anyone
can make a movie and not rehearse even
if you can't put it into the budget like
figure out how to rehearse on weekends
you know I just like that's what I
preach because I it just saves you so
much time while shooting and things you
know you get to work out the Kinks and
um and bumps and you know certain you
know if the blocking doesn't quite work
or you know or an actor's bumping on a
line or whatever you have time to
rewrite it you can re work it with them
and and and also we rehearsed with with
my DP so you know we were changing the
shot list we were coming we were finding
you know better more exciting ways to
shoot a scene you know and and um it so
by the time we got to shooting on the
day we could just fly yeah it's it's so
interesting uh I can't imagine not doing
rehearsals but you hear all about all
these movies and they're just like you
know blocking and figuring it all out on
set it must add so much time to the
production I think that I wouldn't be
able to sleep the night before if like I
didn't know exactly what I was doing
that day you know I don't know how
people do it I think it I think that
that is like I mean yeah some people get
off on on that kind of spontaneity and I
and but I think I mean the thing is is
like something unexpected will always
come up in film making you know what I
mean it's like no matter how much you
prepare too no matter how much you
rehearse something unexpected will
always come up and I think that that's
the beauty of film making but because
for me at least when you're prepared
ahead a time you know exactly what
you're doing coming in then you can make
those pivots very quickly because you've
done all the work and you've done all
the prep I've read people call the film
a twisted erotic Thriller for grown-ups
when you hear that does it excite you do
you agree with it what's your take on
that I mean you know I I think for me
it's
uh I you know I set out to make a
thriller about power dynamics you know
within a relationship and it definitely
has crossovers to the to the erotic
Thriller genre it definitely you know it
has crossovers to a psychological
Thriller genre it has crossovers to a
relationship drama you know but but
ultimately you know I think our jobs as
new filmmakers is is to push genres and
and and uh you know do something new
with it and do something different and
and you know so you know I never wanted
to I never intended to make a
traditional you know film that that was
staying within the confines of any one
particular genre you know for me I was
always the intention here was always to
use the genre and twist it and
manipulate it to to uh shine a light on
you know what I was trying to explore
you know in terms of the story and the
themes you know to show all the ways in
which uh you know women are forced to
play ugly to survive to show you know
the dangers of male inferiority and
using the genre to comment on that you
know um but ultimately I you know if I
I'm you know people should whatever they
want to take away from this film you
know they they should but you know I I
think it's a film that you can't really
put a label on or put in a box I 100%
agree I'm also so curious what it must
be like uh with people walking out of a
theater seeing this and hearing their
conversations um it's uh yeah I'm it's I
mean so far with with all the screenings
we've done it's it's been incredibly
exciting and and Buzzy and and you see
people you know um uh shook you know
like like visibly shook by it you know
you see you see people kind of uh
opening up you know it was it was
interesting I actually I had a screening
um last week where I walked outside the
theater and there were a group of men in
their 60s just and standing in a circle
just opening up about the way that they
were raised and uh talking about their
marriages and their divorces and I'd
never seen a group of men especially in
that age just just like uh feel
comfortable enough to just like you know
talk to each other and and I thought
that that was incredibly exciting you
know I've I've come out of many
screenings and seen women you know
talking or couples Converse or men and
women but I've never seen like a group
of men just like you know it felt like
this movie unlocked uh something that
they had been holding and they felt okay
to talk about and I thought like that
was incredibly rewarding on that note I
need to stop I'm just going to say
sincerely uh congrats on your debut I
look forward to whatever whatever you do
next oh thank you so much I appreciate
that